[Müzik]
öncelikli olarak herkese ben de merhaba
demek istiyorum Evet Korkma ve düşle
gerçekten çok heyecan verici benim
açımdan da bu konuşma yapmak
geçmişe dönük bir takım şeyleri tekrar
tekrar gözden geçirmeme beni yöneltti
Aslında
korkuların nasıl öğreniyoruz Aslında
korkudan öğrenilmiş dürtüler yani
Doğduğumuzda hiçbirimizin Aslında
korkuyu bilmiyoruz
küçük bir Çocuğu düşünün daha yeni
yürümeye başladığını düşünün Rusça acaba
baktığımızda aslında hiçbir şeyden
korkmuyor dediğim sıcak bir şeyleri
elliyor ya da farkında olmadan bir takım
işte Krizlere parmağan sokmaya çalışıyor
O açıdan baktığımızda Aslında korkuyu
zaman öğreniyoruz
Peki bizim ne korkutuyor
öncelikli olarak neyden korktuğumuzu
bilmiyorsak Eğer korkuyoruz yani
korktuğumuz şey bilmemek aslında bizi
korkutabilir
ya da korktuğumuz şeyi bilmemize rağmen
Eğer onunla baş edemeyeceksek korkuyoruz
Peki korkmayı nasıl yönetebiliriz Eğer
korktuğumuz şeyin ne olduğunu bilirsek
ve onunla mücadele etme gücümüz varsa
o zaman Başka edebiliriz O halde
korkmayalım
Peki düşünelim mi Evet
Hepimizin düşleri var hepimiz bu süreç
içerisinde
hayallerimizin bir kısmını düş olarak
kabul ediyoruz bir takım hayallerimiz
bazı zamanlarda çamura dönüşebiliyor
İşte o zaman gerçekten zorlanıyoruz ama
hayallerimizin düşe dönüşmesi de bizim
açımızdan bazı zamanlarda heyecan verir
nasıl heyecan verici oluyor önümüze bir
takım hedefler koymuş oluyoruz
İşte bu hedefleri koyduğumuz zaman bir
takım düşlerimizi hayata geçirmek için
çalışıyoruz
O halde gerçekten
korkmamalıyız ve düşlerimizi
artırmamalıyız
bu süreçte
Biz sağlık alanında çalışan doktorlar
olarak ya da tüm sanat çalışanları
korkmazken
Tabi bunu bir takım altyapı olması
gerekiyor nasıl
korkmadığımız zaman Normalde bir insan
korkmadığı zaman kendine karşı
sorumlulukları vardır ve olabilecek
şeylerden kendisine karşı geri dönüş
olur
ama Bizler
korkmadığımız zaman
oluşabileceği süreçlerde karşımızdaki
hastalarımız da düşünmemiz gerekiyor o
nedenle bizim korkusuzluğumuz bir temele
dayanmalı bir rahat yapısı olmalı
o aşamada ne demek istiyorum
özellikle
yapacağımız tedavilerde uygulayacağımız
süreçlerde birtakım stratejik
uygulamalar da
korkularımızın yenmemiz için
karşımızdaki hastamıza zarar vermememiz
için bir temelini oluşturmamız
gerekiyor bizim tıp alanında bir Latince
bir sözümüz var
Öncelikle onu Eğer zarar verme bizim
temel felsefemiz yola çıkarken birçok
doktorun genellikle budur arkadaşlar
önce zarar verdim
o açıdan baktığımızda korkularımızı
belirli etik değerler üzerine
kurgulayarak bilimsellik üzerinden
yenerek birtakım düşler kurarak
pastalarımıza bir takım uygulamalar
yapmaya çalışıyoruz ve destek olmaya
çalışıyoruz
Aslında bu korkularımızla Baş başa
kaldığımız dönemler oluyor meslek
hayatımız boyunca da örneğin Tıp
Fakültesi bitirdikten sonra ihtisasa
başlıyoruz belli bir alanda uzmanımız
başlıyor ve bu alanda çalışırken bir çok
ameliyatlara katılıyoruz birçok hastamız
yok
bu çalışmalarımız genellikle bizden
büyük hocalarımızın eşliğinde oluyor o
eğitim sürecimizde biz tek başımıza bir
şey yapmıyoruz sadece uzman Olana Kadar
uzmanlık sınavının tamamını bir takım
teorik ve pratik sınavları değiştikten
sonra artık uzman olmayan hak
kazanıyorlar ve ondan sonra artık tek
başına müdahaleleri yapma fırsatımız ve
şansımız olur
İşte bu süreçte
ülkemizdeki uygulamalar gereği uzman
olduktan sonra mecbur hizmete gidiyoruz
hepimiz Kuran çektikten sonra ülkemizin
belli yerlerinde mecnuniyetimizi yapıyor
bu süreç içerisinde Ben de yaklaşık 13
yıl önce ülkemizin çok nadide illerinden
birisinin küçük bir ilçesinde mecbur
Hizmetime başladım kadın doğum uzmanı
olarak
büyük bir heyecanla oraya gittim ve
gittiğim zaman ilk önce şunu gördüm
orada ben tek kadın doğum uzmanı olarak
çalışacaktım
ve bu çalışmamda bütün oraya başvuran
hastalarımızın sorumluluğunu Ben takip
edecek
anestezi uzmanımız orada vardı Ancak
genel cerrahi üroloji uzmanlarımız yoktu
bu süreç içerisinde bütün olabilecek
süreçleri takip etmem gerekiyor
Bir taraftan da doğum yapmak için gelen
bir çok hastamız vardı işte bu aşamada
onları elimden gelenin en iyisini
sunmaya çalışmam gerekiyordu
elimden en iyisi sunmak nedir kadın
doğum alanında anne adayının ve
Bebeğinizin doğum sonrası dönemde
ikisinin de sağlıklı bir şekilde
hastaneler taburcu edip evlerine yolcu
etmez bizim temel amacımız budur
İşte bu süreçte yoğun bir şekilde
hastalarımızın doğum süreçlerini tam
anlamaya başladım çalıştım
doğum vajinal doğumlar gerçekleşiyor
sezerle Dolunay gerçekleşiyor bütün bu
süreç içerisinde bir taraftan
poliklinikte yoğun bir çalışma temposu
var ve ardından Daha sonrasında
şunu öğrendim bizim bütün bu
istatistiklerimiz Sağlık Bakanlığı
Neticede ilerleyen süreçte bütün
yaptığımız doğumlar vajina doğum
seyrediyor Sezen sayıları sesli olarak
Takip ediliyor
bilindiği üzere dünyada ve ülkemizde
sezeryan ile doğumları mümkün olduğu
kadar belli sınırda tutmaya çalışıyoruz
bazı durumlarda sezaryenle doğum yapmak
gerekiyor bazı durumlarda vajinal
çiftimize göre her Bebeğinizin
ve ardından o sene
değerlendirmeler neticesinde
vajinal doğum oranımız bizim son derece
yükseğe çıktı ve ardından Daha
sonrasında o aşamada
Sağlık Bakanlığından insanlık
müdürlüğünden ilgili yerlerden Bu konuda
bir takım ödüllendirmeler yapalım
burada Tıpkı tüm meslektaşlarım olduğu
gibi tüm kadın doğum uzmanları ve tüm
meslektaşlarım olduğu gibi Aslında
hepimiz gittiğimiz yerde canla başla
çalışarak anneyle bebeğimizin en
sağlıklı bir şekilde söyleyeceği
tamamlaması için uğraşıyoruz
o zaman tekrar ilk mecbur hizmete
başladığım gün aklıma geldi Belki bir
takım korkularım vardı ama mecbur
hizmeti tamamladığımda
düşlerimle bu korkuları büyük kısmını
yerleştirmiştim tabi korkuları Yani tek
başınıza olmuyor bir ekiplere yatıyor
orada muhteşem bir ekip vardı orada Eda
hanımlarımız vardı personellerimiz vardı
hep beraber dayanışma içinde çalıştık
herkes gittiğim dönemde her hafta onlara
bir takım eğitimler düzenleyerek teorik
ve pratik bir takım bilgiler vermeye
çalıştım Bunun yanı sıra ilk
gittiğimizde odada yaklaşık bir hasta
odasına 8 kişi yatan vardı
orayı bölmeleri ayırdık bir proje yine
48 saatte her bir odayı özel odaya tek
kişilik odaya çevirdik oradaki gelen
insanlar bir takım Mobilya oraya
bağışladılar beyaz eşya bağışladılar her
odayı yaşına bir hale getir
İşte o sırada ben gerçekten
güçlerimi de gerçekleştirdiğimi fark
ettim
Benim için o süreç Bence de hayatımın en
özel dönemlerinden bir tanesiydi ama
benim yine başka bir düşüm var o da
neydi bir akademisyen olmak ve bunun
yanı sıra tüpü mekanda çalışmak
işte oradan bu güzel günlerden ayrılarak
Üniversitesi Akademik hayatıma başladım
Çünkü bu benim için bir tutkuydu bir
düştü ve düşümü gerçekleşme fırsatım
olacaktı
ve ardından akademik yaratma başladım
üniversitede akademik olarak devam
ederken yine bir taraftan Mesleğimizi
yapıyoruz yine bir taraftan bilimsel
araştırmanıza devam ediyoruz ve yine
birtakım korkularım vardı bir takım
güçlerim vardı
Tıpkı ilk 1978 yılında ilk tüp bebek
uygulamasını yapan
Aslında onun anılarını Ben tekrar tekrar
dönüp Okuyorum işte tabanına anıları var
1978 yılında ilk tüp bebek dünyaya
gelmişken
Aslında Babel hırslı çalışmaları 1960
yılında
1969 yılında yani 9 yıllık çalışma
neticesinde yazdıkları ilk makale Lancer
olarak bildiğimiz çok Saygın bir bilim
dergisi tarafından bilimsel değerinin
olmadığı şeklinde direkt reddediyor 9
yıllık çalışma ama yine heyecanlarını
kaybetmiyorlar korkularını yeniyorlar
düşleri bitmiyor ve tekrar çalışmaya
devam ediyorlar 71 yılında 1971 yılında
farklı bir günden geçerek çalışmaya
devam etmiyorlar bu sefer yumurta
toplama kısmına çok
kısa bilgi verecek olursam bu süreçte
olarak doğurganlık gebelik elde
edebilmek için kadının bir yumurtalı ya
da yumurtası olması gerekiyor bir emrin
yerleşeceği önemli Olması gerekiyor En
az bir tüpünün açık olması gerekiyor ve
bir de sperme ihtiyacı var o aşamada
yumurtaları laboratuvar koşullarında
alıp birleştiriyorlar
ve insanlık tarihi için bu muhteşem
oluşumu bu muhteşem süreci
gerçekleştirip ilk emri
beş yılında ilk gebelik elde ediyorlar
1975 yılında
ancak Maalesef bu bir dış gebelik
çok heyecanlanıyorlar ama sağlıklı bir
RAM içerisinde devam eden bir gebelik
değil o zaman süreç tekrar Bir Hayal
kırıklığıyla sonuçlandı ve ardından yine
pes etmiyor yine düşlerini
kaybetmiyorlar yine düşleri devam ediyor
ve ardından Daha sonrasında
1977 yılında 8 hücreli Bir endoyu
transfer ederek yemeğini Cennet
ediyorlar ve 10 Ekim 1978 tarihinde gece
saat 23.40'da dünyada ilk tüp bebek
İngiltere'de Dünyaya Geliyor gerçekten
insanlık tarihi için inanılmaz bir
süredir
onlar korkmamışlar ve düşen peşinden
etmişti
Benim de bir takım Düşlerim var artık
korkularımın büyük kısmını yenmeye
çalışıyor neden nasıl yenebilirim
kendimi mesleki anlamda yani mesleki
korkularıma
çok iyi bir şekilde teorik bilgimi
iyileştirme geliştirmek pratik cerrahi
bilgimini geliştirmek kendimi eğitmek
birtakım kurslara katılmak ve mümkün
olduğu kadar olabilecek problemlere
karşı hazırlıklı olmak onların
yönetimine karşı hazırlıklı olmak benim
fonksiyonum yenmemesi lazım Peki
Düşlerim nasıl gerçekleşmeye çalışıyorum
işte burada da bir takım hayallerimiz
oldu Tabii ki yine etik çerçevede Tabii
ki bilimsel yöntemler uyarak
Biz
hastalarımıza bir takım faydalar
sağlamaya çalışıyoruz özellikle tüp
bebek alanında yoğun son dönemlerde
rasanıza problemlerden bir tanesi
isteme bilmediğimiz bir nedenle
kadınlarımızı yumurta ve zarfı özellikle
40 yaşın altını boğduğunda
bu alandaki yoğun çalışmalarımız oraya
yaptığınız bir takım uygulamalar
neticesinde gerçekten çok ilginç
sonuçlar almaya başladı Bunlar tabi
Henüz yeni uygulamalar henüz
bilimselliği devam eden bilimsel olarak
kanıtlamamız için daha büyük çalışma
ihtiyacı olan araştırmalar ama hiç
unutmadığım bir hastanın sizinle
paylaşmak istiyorum 28 yaşında bir
hastamız başvurmuştu bize Çift olarak 6
yıllık Evlilerde ve bittiği her yerde
menopozal dönemde oldu ve çocuk sahibi
olamayacağı söylenmiştir Aslında mevcut
değerlendirmemize bakacak olursak
gerçekten Teknik olarak bebek sahibi
olma olasılığı imkansıza yakın
birtakım değerlendirmeler ve
uygulamalara
döneminde kontrole davet ettik fakat
adeti geciktiği için bize başvurduğunda
Morale çok bozuktu
Çünkü yine adet düzensizliği başlayıp
yumurta rezervinde problem olabileceğini
düşünüyorum
geldiğinde ona acaba adet etmesine
nedeniyle gebelik testi yaptırdı mı diye
sorduğunda bunun imkansıza yakın
olduğunu söyledi
ardından ultrasonda baktığımızda o zaman
ultrasonda bakalım diye öneride bulunduk
ultrasonda baktığımızda orada birinci
gebelik çenesi içerisinde bir Kalbi atan
bir bebek görüntüsü gördüm
O nedenle
hastamızın bu aşamadaki yaklaşımı bizim
korkularımız yani mememiz hastamızın
korkularını yenmesi düşlerimiz bütün
Bunların peşinden gitmemiz bizi
inanılmaz sonuçları ilerletelim
burada Belki de bizim maçımızdan en
önemli Detay mümkün olduğu kadar önce
zarar verme ilçesinden uzaklaşmadan
etik ve bilimsel çerçevede bütün bu
kuralları uyarak
mümkün olduğu kadar kendimizi
geliştirerek
çiftlerimizi hastamıza detaylı bilgi
vererek
onları yeterince aydınlatarak Elimizden
geleni en iyisini yapmaya çalışmak
sanırım hepimizin korkuları var
hepimizin güçleri var ama yine Hayat
felsefemiz Korkma ve Düşte olmalı diye
düşünüyorum teşekkür ederim